with japanese prime minister shinzo abe
set to resign
the future of japan's relations with
countries in the region
is suddenly an open question during his
tenure
abe sought to build an alliance with the
united states
india and australia primarily with the
aim of countering china's influence
i'll be speaking to an expert about what
the future of those ties is
but first here's more on the strategic
direction
abe gave japan
shinzo abe steered japan's defense
strategy
in a radical new direction he pledged to
revise japan's pacifist
post-world war ii constitution to
counter
changing security threats in the region
in his first speech to the nation he
said the security of japan is not
someone else's problem
it is a crisis that exists right there
and now
those words set the tone for japan's
defense over his years as prime minister
as abe sought to ward off a newly
assertive china
making incursions into japanese waters
and expanding its territorial claims in
the south china sea
north korea has also posed a
nuclear-armed menace
with frequent missile tests
to demonstrate his muscular stance abe
loosened a ban on
arms exports and in 2015 his party
pushed through
controversial legislation for so-called
collective
self-defense allowing japanese troops to
engage
in overseas combat with allied forces
the law drew strong opposition
domestically and a later push to revise
the pacifist constitution
failed
abe's military reforms and containment
diplomacy
have upset china its largest trading
partner
allies like u.s president donald trump
have confronted china with sanctions
but abe's had to find the balance
between competing and cooperating with
china
despite his radical security ambitions
a needle his successor will likely also
have to thread
so what happens next simon denyer is the
washington post bureau chief for japan
and the koreas
and he joins me now from tokyo simon
i'd like to look at japan's relations
with china first
where do you see them headed after
shinzo abe steps down
there's been quite a lot of ups and
downs in the relationship between japan
and china they started off
really badly under rabe's tenure he's
worked quite hard to improve them
actually in the last
few years so you know it's going to be
very interesting
to see whether china tries to exploit
this
uh and push its territorial claims to
the senkaku islands it's already
threatening
to do that it's been more active around
the senkaku diyou islands as
of course as china calls them um so
so we may see china as it's done with
india seeing an opportunity to push its
territorial claims
in the absence of our bay and while this
leadership transitions going on that's
something to keep an eye on
there was some talk of a so-called new
era in ties
between japan and china and it was
mostly down to shinzo abe he in fact
visited china as well to try and
smoothen things over
do you think that is a thing of the past
now
i mean i don't think it's necessarily a
thing of the past i think that whoever
comes in
after abe is likely to continue to try
to do this but you know
japan china relations they're never
going to be best of friends they do
have wartime issues between them japan
is an ally of america
china and the united states are
you know clearly not seeing eye to eye
far from it so
japan's kind of caught in the middle are
based on quite a good job i think of
patching things up and not letting that
sort of
not letting the china relationship
deteriorate
but i don't think you know we're really
talking about we're ever talking about
a golden era we're talking about sort of
both sides
putting their differences aside and just
getting on with things
more than more than real friendship
japan was also considered an
important partner for the united states
india and australia in the
so-called indo-pacific region do you see
that cooperation simon continuing
and broadly speaking yes i do i think
that you know japan is very committed to
being part of an alliance
of democracies in asia and beyond the
pacific region as you say
um it's going to be very interesting to
see how the relationship with the united
states develops though
if trump if president trump does get
another term in office i think that
japan probably would have liked to have
had
someone like shinzo abe who gets on very
well with trump
as their prime minister uh trump hasn't
really taken aim at japan but he's
always kind of threatened
to so it could be quite rocky for japan
if you don't have arbeit there and if
trump were
to win another term obviously if it's
biden
and whoever succeeds arbay i think
relations between japan and the us will
be pretty will be pretty smooth
lots of ifs and buts there but plenty to
watch out for but thanks so much
for this conversation simon daniel in
tokyo thank you so much
pleasure now there's a certainly tragic
irony and the fact that
the man who was elected to office eight
years ago primarily because of his
economic policies
will now leave the country as he himself
says in one of the worst economic crises
for decades
seven years eight months that's how long
shinzo abe was in office
longer than any other prime minister in
japan when he announced his resignation
citing health reasons
he focused on the crippling effects of
the pandemic on the japanese
economy this year's second quarter saw
economic growth shrink by almost
28 and how will things shape up without
rb the markets reacted to the news of
his resignation with pessimism
initial reports saw the nikkei index
dropped 2.1
by close of trading it was still 1.4
down
what's the mood on the streets of tokyo
i'm surprised he looked really tired but
i didn't think he would resign i wish he
could work harder and stay on in office
a bit longer
i've been wanting him to resign for a
long time
shinzo abe is a controversial figure in
japan partly because of his emphasis
on his public image in 2012 he
introduced his ambitious economic
programme
naming it unabashedly after himself
with ergonomics i will increase jobs and
incomes and revitalize the countryside
ubinomics was about easing monetary
policy the japanese central bank
cranked up the money press flooding the
market with fresh new
notes there were also credit financed
economic stimulus packages
initially the programme did increase
confidence both in the economy
and among the japanese population but
the risks of abanomics
soon became clear the program over
leveraged the economy to the point of
sovereign bankruptcy and led to a loss
of confidence on capital markets
the already struggling japanese economy
has been hit hard by the corona virus
with abe out of the picture it's up to
someone else to pull japan
out of the crisis
i spoke to professor jeff kingston
director of asian studies at temple
university japan in tokyo
and referring to shinzo abe's economic
strategy
i asked him what worked well and what
didn't
well the list of what did work well i
think is relatively
short um i think he was
good in terms of promoting free trade he
cut a deal with the
eu he also rescued the tpp
but on what didn't work he never
delivered
on structural reforms which were the
third
era of abenomics which are supposed to
improve
productivity he never delivered on
womenomics
he said he was going to help women shine
but
that hasn't happened there has been an
expansion of women's employment but it's
been in poorly paid dead-end careers in
non-regular employment
so that hasn't really worked out either
generally speaking
households and all sorts of polls say
they're not feeling the love
you know they didn't feel the trickle
down a lot of people dismiss avenomics
as welfare for the wealthy
corporations have done well hedge fund
managers have done well
but the average person doesn't see much
increase at all in their pay packet
and so the general sense of well-being
has not improved
all right and uh how big a role is or
has the pandemic been
playing in all this
um nomics was pretty much dead in the
water
you know at least two three years ago it
really was fading
so was already in trouble and then last
fall
he introduced an increase in the
consumption
tax which is regressive and that really
sent
consumption plummeting downward and
that's the real problem of the pandemic
is that people's income is shrinking a
lot of people are furloughed they're
losing their bonuses whatever
so there's been shrinking consumption
and
as people you know anticipate that the
economic typhoon
is going to be gathering force over the
coming months
people are battening down the hatches
spending less
and that creates sort of a downward uh
cycle
and so it doesn't look too bright so
problem for abe
is what's his legacy hobby nomics
certainly is a failure
he was hoping that the olympics might be
a feel-good send-off
but that doesn't look very likely and so
his pandemic response has generally
drawn
heavy criticism from the public they
don't think he's done very well so
he's tired out and that was professor
jeff kingston from temple university in
tokyo talking
to us earlier what time to bring in
chelsea delaney now
our financial market correspondent in
frankfurt chelsea good to see you
tell me what is the financial world
saying about shinzo abe's resignation
it has been a bit of a shock to the
markets and we've definitely seen that
reflected in
both the japanese stock market and also
the currency markets um
obviously there had been reports that
shinzo abe had been in and out of the
hospital
the past couple of weeks but nobody
really saw this coming today and
of course this does come at a terrible
time for japan when their economy is
facing
a record contraction shinzo abe
obviously a controversial figure but he
has been seen as really a stable hand
over the past several years so the loss
of that in this
really dire economic situation is a bit
of a blow but obviously the big question
now is is what's going to happen with uh
abenomics
and exactly and with 20 seconds to go
you have the chance to tell us who could
be the possible successor of
shinsu abe
there are a lot of names on on the
potential successor list it likely is
going to be somebody from his party the
liberal
the liberal democrats and that likely
will also
mean that abanomics is not gone maybe it
will have a new name but this
this policy of aggressive stimulus of
aggressive monetary policy is likely
going to stay in place with the economy
in this shape all right chelsea delaney
in frankfurt thank you
you